conçu pour des travaux de soudure
convertis en magasin de meubles si le
point de départ de bien des Ukrainiens
qui arrivent dans la capitale Albertine
pour y commencer une nouvelle vie
rien de luxueux tout est usagé et pour
ceux qui ont tous laissé derrière ces
articles de base ont une grande valeur
35 bénévoles assure le roulement
d'entrepôt maison Pen à fournir à la
demande chaque semaine 75 familles
reçoivent ici de quoi meubler
minimalement leur tout premier logement
en sol canadien en Alberta seulement ce
sont pour moi de 20 000 ukrainiers qui
sont arrivés depuis un an
week canal
safe space
freedomis qui explose classe d'anglais
qui débordent
l'impression de citer une crise
humanitaire en Alberta depuis des mois
le Congrès ukrainien alberté réclame de
l'aide supplémentaire à la province mais
la réponse se fait toujours attendre
ils sont en sécurité mais pour les 160
000 Ukrainiens arrivaient au pays depuis
un an les vies est loin d'être facile
you Bove cauchemaine et ses deux garçons
sont arrivés à maintenir 6 mois après
avoir traversé la Pologne et l'Allemagne
leur parcours s'est arrêté en Alberta
audiobov avait déjà de la famille
tout recommencer mais cette mère de 40
ans estime tout de même qu'elle a de la
chance et elle a pu trouver un toit et
un emploi rapidement
Dennis malgré la barrière de la langue
ils se sont rapidement fait des amis et
t'aider
mais ils ont de bonnes notes commerces
et très important pour moi gilwave
où ils habitaient à Mario Paul a été
rasé depuis leur départ leur ville a été
l'une des plus défigurées par la guerre
l'Ukraine lui manque mais il ne sait pas
si un jour elle y retournera
pour les évacuer la dernière année a été
éprouvante mais en Alberto ils ont pu
trouver du réconfort et un peu de chez
eux grâce à une imposante diaspora
présente dans la province depuis un
siècle la troupe de danse ukrainienne
shumca a accueilli à bras ouverts de
jeunes danseurs tout juste arrivé au
pays
de le vivre Mariana Slavie tu ne se
doutait pas que ses enfants pourraient
préserver leur identité crinienne
pour la troupe accueillir ces nouveaux
danseurs étaient une évidence ils sont
nous ils font partie de nous et comme ça
ils font partie de la famille quand il
arrive
les bénévoles de la première heure
commencent à se fatiguer mais après un
an de guerre les queues se perpétuent
maintenant par ceux qui sont récemment
arrivés Sofia meublé sur l'appartement
ici d'abord bénévole dans l'entrepôt
pendant quelques mois elle en est devenu
la coordonnatrice
je mets des tout le monde et je fais de
mon mieux pour toutes les familles comme
la mienne si cette mère de deux enfants
elle sait à quel point la transition
peut être ardue I want to say
toys surtout pour les enfants parce que
le séjour au Canada soit temporaire ou
permanent et peu importe combien de
temps durera encore la guerre la
diaspora ukrainienne continuera de faire
tout un son possible pour adoucir les
preuves du déracinement